네, 안녕하세요. 어, 오늘은 상가를
투자할 때 보통 입지나 수익률을 많이
분석을 하는데 임차인 업종은 분석하지
않더라고요. 제가 국세청에서 통계
자료를 좀 가져왔는데이 통계 자료를
보면서 어떤 업종들이 좀 많이
살아남고 어떤 업종들이 많이 폐업을
하는지 오늘 자세하게 설명드리도록
하겠습니다. [음악]
그래서 주제는 내 건물 임차인 3년
뒤에도 있을까요라는 주제인데 제가네
가지 PPT를 좀 준비했어요.
[음악]
그래서 이걸 좀 같이 보면서 이야기를
나눠 보도록 하겠습니다. 어, 우선
첫 번째로 2024년 폐업률이 사상
최초로 100만 명을 돌파했습니다.
[음악] 그래서 정말 많은 그
자영업자분들이 폐업을 했고 그 아마
25년도는 이거보다 더 높을 거
같아요. [음악]
심지어는 코로나 때는 폐업자 수가
제가 알고 있기로는 한 89만 명
정도 되는데 그거보다 더 높은
폐업률을 기록하고 있습니다. 그러니까
열 개 업체가 창업을 하면 여덟 개가
폐업을 합니다. 이게 2023년
기준인데 지금은 아마 더 높을 것
같아요. 거의 창업하면 폐업하는
확률을 조만간에 뛰어넘지 않을까
싶습니다. 그리고 5년 생률을 보면은
창업한지 5년이 [음악] 지났는데 한
여섯 곳은 사라집니다. 그니까 열 곳
중에 여섯 곳은 5년 이내에 이제
폐업을 하는 거죠. 임차인 [음악]
다섯 명 중에 두 명은 3년 내에
폐업을 합니다. 그 계약 기간 동안
[음악] 버틸 수 있는 업종인지 미리
확인을 하는게 되게 중요하고 그리고
지금 소매업이랑 음식점률 폐업률이
되게 높은데 이게 전체 44% 정도
된다라고 합니다. 그래서 제가 좀
세부적으로 준비를 했는데 3년 이내
이제 생존율이 미용실이 되게 높아요.
그래서 미용실이 아무래도 저희가 직접
가서 머리를 해야 되는 거기 때문에
미용실은 그래도 수익성이 [음악] 잘
나오나 봐요. 그다음에 교습 학원도
낮은 편입니다. 그리고 편의점. 당장
우리가 막 써야 되는 것들은 편의점을
가야지 있기 때문에 편의점도 생존률이
좀 높은 것으로 보여지고 그다음에
의원이나 병원도 되게 높습니다. 이게
아무래도 진입 장벽이 좀 있잖아요.
그리고 이제 뭐 인테리어 비용이나
이런 것도 많이 [음악] 쓰기
때문에이 생존율이 많이 높은 거 같고
그다음에 이제 재과점도 되게 높은 거
같아요. 그래서 동네 빵집이라든지
제가 얼마 전에도 그 김영모 갖다
왔는데 사람이 바글바글하더라고요.
제가 점도 폐염률이 그렇게 높지 않은
업종 중에 하나인 거 같습니다.
그거와 반해서 커피 음료점. 지금
커피점이 과열이 경쟁이 너무 [음악]
심해요. 되게 최적과 커피들도 굉장히
많이 나와 가지고 폐염률이 그래도
높은 [음악] 편에 속하는 거
같습니다. 어, 제가 체크리스트를 좀
준비를 했는데 우선 첫 번째로 인차인
업종이 3년 내 생존이 평균 [음악]
이상인가?이 이 지금 업종 데이터
같은 경우에는 국세청에서 통계를 낸게
있거든요. 그래서 국세청 데이터가
어떻게 보면 [음악] 제일 정확해요.
국세청이 폐업률을 정확히 알고 있기
때문에 국세천 사이트에 들어가서 내가
지금 드리려고 하는 지금이 [음악]
들어오려고 하는 업종들을 검색해
보시는게 되게 중요합니다. 그리고 두
번째로 온라인 전환에 취약한 업종인지
[음악] 그래서 아까 예를 들렸던
홈업, 의류업, 뭐 화장품 이거는
사실 온라인에 [음악] 굉장히
취약하거든요. 이런 오프라인에 꼭
있어야 되는 업종인지 아니면
온라인으로 대체가 되는 업종인지를
파악하는게 되게 중요한 거 같습니다.
그리고 세 번째로 이건 항상 [음악]
말씀드리는 건데 지금 임대료가 매출이
최소한 임대료에 열배는 나오는지
보셔야 됩니다. 그래서 예를 들어서
임대료가 1천만 원이다라고 하면 월
매출이 1억이 넘어야 돼요. 그래야지
버틸 수 있습니다. 미리 확인하는게
[음악] 굉장히 좀 중요합니다.
그리고 임차인이 월세 협상을 요청해
오는 경우가 있거든요. 중간에
[음악] 갑자기 임대를 깎아 달라.
아니면 장사가 안 된다. 중간에
나간다라고 하는 업종들이 있는데 그런
부분을 좀
>> [음악]
>> 체크하시면 좋을 것 같습니다. 그래서
제가 마지막으로 좀 전체적으로
설명드릴게 건물을 사지만 [음악]
저희는 실질적으로 임차인이 굉장히
중요해요. 그래서 임차인에 따라서
건물 가치가 달라지고 가격이
올라가기도 하고 떨어지기도 합니다.
그러다 보니까 뭐 임대료뿐만 아니라
임차인 업종들을 굉장히 좀 신경을
많이 쓰셔야 되고 음식점이나
소매업들이 폐업률이 굉장히 높아요.
45%입니다. 전체 이런 [음악]
업종을 드릴 때는 미리 사전에 사업자
등록증을 받던지 아니면 다른 곳에서
이제 장사를 하고 있다라고 하면은
얼마나 잘하고 있는지 이런 것들을
되게 신중하게 파악해야 [음악] 될
부분이 있고 그리고 이제 카페 같은
경우에는 경쟁이 워낙 치열하다 보니까
진짜 신규로 뭐 기존에 카페 안
하셨던 분이 [음악] 갑자기 내가
차려서 해보겠다라고 하시는 분들을
검토를 많이 해야 되는 부분이
[음악] 있는 거 같습니다. 온라인
전환에 되게 취약한 업종들은 신중하게
볼 필요가 있고 그리고 선호해야 될
업종들 어 제가 아까 말씀드렸던 그런
업종뿐만 아니라 무조건 내가 여기
오프라인 와서 해야 된다. 여기
현장에 와서 해야 된다라는 업종들이
있거든요. 이런 업종들을 유심히 보실
필요가 있는 거 같습니다. 그래서
제가 지금 이것뿐만 아니라 그
업종들을 또 데이터로 정리한게
있거든요. 댓글을 남긴 거를
캡처해서메일로 보내 주시면은 제가 그
업종들 세분한 거를메일로 보내
드리도록 할테니까 여러분들 많은 댓글
남겨 [음악] 주시면 좋을 것
같습니다. 네, 그래서 오늘 영상
여기까지 하고요. 여러분들이 영상이
마음에 드셨다면 구독과 좋아요, 알림
설정까지 [음악] 좀 부탁드리도록
하겠습니다. 오늘 영상 여기까지
하겠습니다. 감사합니다.